good afternoon we are live now
dear attendees welcome to another event
within the fcth council europe webinar
series
the fch council europe is an industry
organization with a mission to advance
ubiquitous soul fiber-based connectivity
to the whole of europe
and today we have a pleasure to host a
webinar organized by three members of
ours
namely settix key pro and package front
and
cool delivers today's event jointly
but before we dump into the topic of
today's webinar please allow me to walk
you through
the upcoming events within our webinar
series
on 30th of june fcch council europe's
investor committee
will deliver a webinar that will launch
our brand new guide to successful fiber
business models on
8th of july we will host a webinar
organized by our member company comsco
and on 13th of july we will host a
webinar organized by the
fth council's global alliance announcing
the results of the global future work
survey
um next slide please
even we have received your consent you
will be notified about the future
webinars within our series
please note that this webinar will be
recorded and accessible digitally
after the session you may use the
questions section of the platform to
pose your questions to the attention of
our speakers
these questions should the time permit
will be addressed during the q a session
at the end of the webinar
and now without further ado please
welcome our first speaker nick thomas
who is in charge of uk and ireland
business development aesthetics
over to you nick
thank you my name's nick
i live in lower camborne and i would
like to tell you about the fantastic new
fiber broadband service we now have from
zip fiber the whole family can now watch
as many streaming services they like
which is a big relief in a large family
during the recent lockdown i can tell
you
behind the scenes a team has been
working hard
to ensure that zip fiber provides one of
the best services around
like many other people i was totally
unaware of just what it takes to bring
fast broadband to my house but i became
so interested in the whole process
that i actually met some of the zip
fiber team
three of the team are now going to show
you in a few steps just what it takes to
have my service delivered
firstly daniel a project manager will
show how zip fiber planned the network
then mika as a deployment specialist
will show how my house was incorporated
into the network
and finally teemo as operations manager
will show how i actually receive my
connection
the important part so i'd first like to
introduce danielle
a project manager from zip fiber who had
to decide just how the network in lower
camborne should look
um thank you nick um hello all uh this
is daniel
i'm a project manager at zip fiber and
lead the network planning team
i'm also in charge of validating the
designs made by
our planners and subcontractors
zip fiber is an operator that has been
growing rapidly in the last few years
our plan is to connect roughly 200k
customers in the next five years
we are also continuously participating
in the different
rfps launched by the government uh for
connecting rural areas
and have our own plans for serving dense
areas
our group is present in many countries
all over europe
in the next minutes we will show the
whole process from planning the network
to connecting ics house i will uh
present the different phases involved in
the planning of an ftth network
our objectives as an operator and
finally uh the importance of
automation as an essential tool for
enhances
enhancing the design process
in the early stages of our design
process
we need to do a preliminary study so as
to
evaluate the feasibility of the project
in terms of
costs make decisions on which endpoints
are subject
to be served by our company and which
ones will be
discarded this is all based on the
amount of civil work
necessary to reach such endpoints and
if it's affordable on our side answer on
time
to the different rfps launched by the
government as well
then there's the hld high level design
phase
where we define our network architecture
we also work side by side with our
optical equipment provider
in this matter here we evaluate the
splitting level uh definite location of
olts
and design the network the feeder
network and etc
uh we define the different phases of the
project
uh in the first phases we prioritize the
areas
where infrastructure is already present
in our case we'll use existing pia
infrastructure
we also need to define how we'll do the
connections uh overhead
underground or both um also obtain
a more accurate list of materials so we
can get quotes from our equipment
provider
and start defining teams for working on
the field
in the next phases which involve
detailed low-level design
we need to incorporate the information
coming from
field surveys find at the drop
connections
get cabling diagrams splice plans uh
prepare the
to build documents and also manage some
subcontractor teams like field service
and for
low level design in the beginning our
networks
we designed our networks manually
however as volume increased
and work execution speeded up it was a
challenging to keep up with
the good quality this is why we decided
to look into design automation and after
a broad evaluation
we ended up adopting the solution from
the best provider
according to our scorecard with this
approach we were able to make possible
uh
the study of uh different scenarios by
working on the hld
uh based on uh existing data from
various
gis sources uh obtain an accurate model
of a network
the ability to rerun initial deeds by
incorporating
the results of field surveys um allowed
us
to produce accurate designs obtain
more reliable and homogeneous results
across the board
and also in control scatters um
have more control of the network design
and building
by elaborating the control tools that
will allow to
monitor the work of subcontractors
and drastically reduce mental work
it remains only necessary for detailed
design
in difficult situations where the
planner interpretation and experience
are required as a result we were able to
beat effectively for state funded areas
and also
secure the delivery of our commercial
build programs
overall we considerably improved the
productivity
scalability we have a faster and more
predictable scale
and uh the quality of our processes and
deliveries
uh increased as well
so uh the journey to bring the fiber to
nick's house
started as it follows first i logged
into the company's inventory system
where the existing data about the area
was stored
so here i create
a plan a brownfield
area in a lower canberra
in the uk so
i select my area
then export the input data for my
project
so uh the information on the
addresses the available infrastructure
and the olt position
and then we configured the project in
our design automation software
in lower kenburn we decided to implement
a gpa
network with two splitting levels of one
eight each for a total of
one to sixty four
we also used as uh input data
uh the layers coming from the inventory
systems uh aforementioned so
uh the bt dogs the uh bt ireline
and the roads for new build
we also define the cabling rules and
equipment
to use based on the recommendations made
by our equipment provider
and network specialists
and once we have set up the project we
run the software
and the system calculates the network
automatically
from here we can obtain several
output layers
such as cables
doxxed and microducts and microducts
assemblies as well
we have the splitters
and the splice closures
and some other layers as well
we can also estimate the cost for
endpoint which
helps us define the different phases of
the project
in this example the red point indicates
that connecting
this endpoint will be very expensive as
a lot of the new infrastructure needs
to be built it's likely that we'll leave
this house for the last phase of the
project
unless the customer wants uh to take on
the fiber
i can also use the tools on the map to
make
manual modifications uh which might
result from the
from the field survey so
in this case i am going to create
a box uh for the ensemble of houses
that are surrounding the aerial
infrastructure
so i select my houses
i assigned the parent node
of this these houses
um i'll also force the connection for
house
44 to be overhead
and when i'm done i run the server
and the system calculates all the
elements uh
one more time
we can also see here the the polygon
the service area of this box
once i finished the design i'm able to
obtain
um a bill of materials and financial
information uh on my project
with a detailed description of all the
elements of a network
and their cost so in this example
we can see the total cost of the feeder
network
and the total cost of a distribution
network with
all the elements the equipment the nodes
the splitters the cables uh the linear
infrastructure that was used
and and the poles and manholes
we can also have a first splice plan
for the early phases of the of the
building
and a cabling diagram
also a link budget report
and also a docked diagram with
the information on which cable is
within each docked
now that the design is ready i can
export the results
to our inventory software this is easily
done through a plugin
that allows a seamless integration
and now i'll hand over to my colleague
mika vato who is a deployment specialist
of our company
for the next part to cover thank you
very much
yeah thank you daniel let me just
share my webcam so and my screen
so
uh today i'm working for
cheap fiber and on a deployment team
and what we did we got
a plan from daniel the fiber plan
and what we are gonna now do is uh
to build the axle network document it
uh the passive network and uh
have an accurate build documentation
when we are building that one
for the our deployment team the most
important things is to get the plan
and make the data available for everyone
who needs that one
and from the data then we are building
it's
extremely important for us that we have
accurate
and detailed documentation
that one will reduce the price of the
operating the network and it will also
give us more value to the network what
we have
and then we are of course doing
following all the projects what we are
doing
as a cheap fiber we don't have our own
civil war team but we are using
contractors and with them we are
following the progress but today i'm
gonna
focus the two first ones uh square
the boxes what we have there so
i will show how we are giving the data
to our contractors
and how do we create
accurate and very good high detailed
documentation out of it
as we all know like a building a network
is
uh is a challenging one of the
challenges is the
that you have lots of different type of
documents you have
excel sheets you have diagrams you have
a maps
and when we started we found out that we
have
so many different files
which we were sharing we were
creating a project files we were giving
those ones
and every single change we had to update
then all the files there
sometimes it meant that we also had to
print out
complete everything completely again and
that was a time consuming
for our team so we tried to find a new
a better solution how we can share all
that same information
with our contractors and what we came
out
up with that one is that we give an
access to our
our system so that all the contractors
everyone who needs that information they
can have
and access that information
so this one is what i'm going to show
today that how we actually gave an
access to all of our contractors
and how that one works
is like this so
we have here is a
area which we haven't built it's a red
and we can see
a circuit which are highly detailed
circuits
fiber level detail all of these ones and
we can see that there's couple which are
ordered we have a customer information
so we know that we will build this one
at this point nick haven't
actually built but that's a nick is
living next to
this area we are going to actually build
that one as well
and as you can see
we have all this information here
and what i have created is an access
area
now using this access area i can
actually give an
access to everyone about not everyone
but
which i choose to see everything what is
inside
so in this case our contractor i have
given an access
to this one so they will only see
the things what they need if i show it
on
my contractor account that i will log in
on this side everything what you can
actually see is
working on the sas and through the
browser so that's why it's possible
so this was the area and as you can see
our contractors can only see
the small part of our network so they
cannot actually do any changes
to the network what we don't want them
want to to do changes
they can see that there is a circuit
they don't see the customer information
but they do see the circuits which needs
to be built
and then they have all the only the
information what they need for building
this one
so as you can
see that there's a
this uh our existing uh closure
which made us our life a lot easier is
this one that the
contractor now can actually access all
the
information directly from our database
this means that all the changes what we
make
the contractor will also see that one se
at the same time we don't have to
reprint anything we don't have to update
anything
when they go to the site they have a
laptop or tablet with them
and they can actually access all the
information
while on the field and they will always
have the latest information
so this one reduce the amount of time
what we are using printing and doing
that kind of
work packages for our contractors
now our contractor has been so fast that
they have
actually built this network and it's
quite different
than what this was actually planned
and for us we have granted access
to our this contractor that they can
actually move
all the elements so this one means that
when they have
done everything they have as built
documentation as
accurate as a few centimeters
we can they can actually move all the
plant
items to the correct places
and this way build high detailed
documentation as you remember we already
had
documentation fiber level documentation
but now with what i'm showing here
moving these elements to the right
places
we can make it sure that when someone
else comes
and needs to go and dig in this area or
making a trench
we can show them exactly where our
cables where our contacts are
and that one has reduced a lot
of our faults in our network there won't
be any faults anymore because we have
very high accurate information where our
all of elements are
moving these ones is also something that
we use to do it by ourselves
when we had the desktop version but
this one the system what we are using
now
allows us to allows that one that anyone
who has an access to here
who we are of course making sure that
the right person has access we have a
same as online banking level of
security here and whoever has an access
they can do this all documentation for
us
reducing the time what we need to do
and it actually has also increased
or we actually get the information from
the field faster
we have a few contractors who are
actually doing this one
uh directly from field when they do the
aspirin documentation
they go afterwards they go to god they
upload
the surveys to do our system
and then what they do is that they
update it straight away so we have
actually in the matter of minutes
we have that information
that this one is built now as you can
see
everything has been moved so this area
is uh we are very accurate here that we
know exactly that the
our ducts where they are
and we can send a map for example
someone who comes and build
that yes we have here existing ones
existing docks so be careful that they
are here
now what the contractor can still do is
to update
all the elements here well now
updating actually just our ducts
the cables are something that
we are deploying after customer order
but with this one we can see that now
everything here
has been built has been documented
and we have a high accurate information
now what i can also show you this
with this contractor is mobile use
so what we also have is we have a mobile
uh interface as well i'm using it uh on
my web browser but usually this one is
used through the
mobile phone and this is extremely
handy handy tool
for our contractor who goes and actually
installs the cable because what they can
do
as you can remember that we had a few
customers who are waiting the fiber
already
so what they can go they can go and
install
the cable and they can
save all the information
and with that one all this information
is done actually in a matter of seconds
that we will get the information back in
our office
that these cables has been installed and
we can continue
with the installing all with the
operation side
if i log in back to
this normal view desktop view
we can see that already there's a hint
of green
in a cables which we updated
so if i select this one you can see that
now it's uh
it's already been built and if i update
this my
own view what i see from our network
just updating this one you can see that
everything
which was planned is now actually in use
mode
and i can see that they are built
now what i can do by i'm doing now by
hand
this is something what we can to do
through api as well
but what i'm just gonna do here is that
i will
put this one connection as a
pre-connected this
is actually nick's connection
and then we have the other ones which
are in already built
so i put that they are soon in use
the fiber for them has been built and
then the second one's too
that they are now ready
now doing this one then our operation
site will get the information fast again
when we do this change they will see it
straightaway themselves as well
and they are able to deliver
a connection for the customers and how
do we do that one in a cheap fiber
it's gonna be timo who's gonna be
telling talking about that one so
let me give my flaw to demo
and our operations great
thank you mika it looks like we are
progressing very nicely here
so let me see i'll just show my screen
can you see my screen now
yes we can yes thank you okay
yeah thanks mika this is going really
well so now we have
only the last steps left so to
nick to order the fiber he has heard
that his neighbors are getting this
super fast
nice internet connection from us at zip
fiber
and then the last step to actually order
the fiber
connection itself i mean
we could have built the fiber already in
the same phase as
mika showed you before but nick is
ordering the fiber as a separate
thing here so there are many different
workflows that we are following
and before i show you
how this works in the products
themselves
uh i'll just show you a couple of one
slide
to explain because i'm going to jump a
little bit between different
products so it's easier to follow what
i'm going to show you in a second
so first of all nick can enter
our portal to see
if fiber is deliverable for his address
and that request comes to the gis system
that
mika just showed you where you have the
fiber planning
and the gis system then returns to
the portal if the fiber is available
and after you as you can probably guess
in this example the fiber is available
so we can proceed and
nick can order the fiber connection
the fiber connection order comes now to
the
bss system which will then
send a work order back to the gis system
so the installation guys know that they
need to do the final
fiber drop and the bss system will also
instruct the network orchestrator to
configure the network
the active equipment like olts and onts
and after this step the installation is
ready
we have the fiber installed we have the
active equipment in place
and we are ready to proceed to deliver
services
to nick and
nick can do that by himself by
ordering the services via portal
so when he has selected the service
the activation comes the bss system
which will then
order the network orchestrator to
configure the network so that the
service is delivered
and after that we have a happy new
subfiber customer online
so let me start
from the face where nick checks if the
fiber is
available for him so this is
uh steve fiber's homepage
where where you can ask for the
fiber availability so nick just types in
his
address and pushes for the check
availability button
so now the portal communicates with the
gis
system so if we jump there and i have
already opened the right
address bigly court and it's this blue
dot here
so if i check that and the service
area yeah we can see
here that the nick's address
it is within the area we are currently
building
and if we double click here
we can also see
the services that are available for nick
so if we would activate the services at
the same time
as we uh build the fiber we could do
that as well
but as said this time nick will
order the services as a separate step
later on
so let's jump back to the
portal
so yes we can deliver
fast fiber to nick
so we can proceed to ordering
the fiber service
by clicking here and we just
fill in customer details
and push the order now button
so now the portal will communicate with
the bss system instead of the gis
so if we go to the bss
system instead and open the
customer page
we can see that nick was now created
here as a
new customer and the information that he
typed in on the home page
is now here on the customer card
and typically in this phase we had see
fiber we
do some credit checks and
work with the vouchers that we use here
in uk
but when we are ready to proceed
we go into this subscriptions
tab and activate
a service for the installation fiber
installation with in this case called
this cheap on
key pro but before i do that
let's jump back to the gis system
and i have already opened the circuit
that we are going to use that mika also
was playing with
and you can see that the circuit is in
this pre-connected state
meaning that the circuit can be used but
it hasn't been assigned to
any customer yet
and we can also see that there's no
customer data so there's no customer
name customer number or anything like
that
so let's go back to the bss system again
and we activate the installation service
so now the bss system communicated with
the
js system so if we update this page now
like that we see that the state of the
circuit was changed to this soon in use
meaning that the circuit should be
completed now
and we also push the customer data to
the js system so it's stored there as
well
so the vss system also send an email
to the installation team so they know
that there's a new work order
you could also use some workflow
management tools in this
that can be integrated into this
solution but in any way the guys will go
out now
draw the cable and install
the ont unconfigured just plug it in
and when they have done everything they
will
complete the circuit like this
so now the circuit is in use
so if we jump back to the bss again and
update this page so we can see now that
the installation service is
active and that means that the bss
system has always
also already communicated with the
network
orchestrator so nick is going to be
connected on this ont
port 27 here so we change the status of
that port to customer running meaning
that it's now in
in use and we
also created the configuration
for the ont so in when it was plugged in
it automatically gets the right
configuration from the network
orchestrator
and that's it now the network is
up and running and we are ready to
start activating services so the last
step the network orchestrator did was it
activated
a portal service meaning that when nick
now connects to his ont he will be
directed to this self-service portal
that we have
and the first step here now
that nick needs to do is to
log in to the pages
and the system recognizes that this is
the first time nick is
logging in so it will ask if the
customer details are correct
and accept terms and conditions
and register as a user
and it will also ask if this is nick's
address
so this is just to double check that the
patching was
done correctly and this is nick's
address
so we can proceed
and actually log in to the self-service
page
we at sifer we are an open access
operator meaning that
we have multiple service providers
in our network that nick can choose from
but he can also look at the services
directly and see all the services that
are
available for him in his address
and when we compare this and look at the
prices and all that
it looks like this internet basic is
like a
very very good option so let's
choose that one
and now we need to
keep password so kids don't go and order
services on their own
and also select activation date
and that's it now the service is
activated
so if i close this and jump to
my pages
we can see the service here and if
nick had like a binding period or
anything like that that would be shown
here as well
now he doesn't have any binding period
so he can actually terminate his
service at any time he wants
so let's jump back to bb bss system and
see
what happened there let's open next
customer card again
and we can see the service here
and if we click it open
we can see all the commercial terms and
conditions that are valid for him the
billing
information and stuff like that and
the bss system also uh communicated now
with the network orchestrator which
configure the network
so that the service is active
meaning that when nick now uh connects
to his omt next time he can use intel
internet as normal and won't be
redirected
to the portal so now nick is a
new customer at the zip fibers
network and yep we have shown the whole
whole trip from planning the network
all the way to activating the
fiber or the internet access to
nick's address so
nick now you are a new customer
in zip fibers network and you have a
super fast
internet how does that feel
well thanks guys i'm delighted to say
it's working very well and i'm using it
at the moment
the good news for all the attendees is
that zip fiber is going to go on the
stock market soon so i can recommend
buying some shares great service
thank you very much hopefully that was a
clear demonstration exactly how i've got
my internet
in three easy steps thank you very much
guys
we now have time for questions and
answers there's a question
tab that you can use we've already got
some questions in so i'll fire away if i
may
uh i think this one's probably for mika
there were three different systems in
your presentation
would we need to integrate those
different systems or do you can take
care of this
well we have designed our solutions to
be
that they are compatible using
interfaces so we are using api
interfaces and other interfaces
to make sure that everything works
seamlessly
and also the silencers are able to
interface and
exchange data from in many use
different type of use cases as well
good well thanks for that uh the next
question i think perhaps all of you can
answer it separately
a question from somebody saying we have
many we sorry we have currently
a couple of hundred homes connected and
will grow here in the uk
how many new staff do operate operators
like us need if we want to embrace these
solutions that's a very good question
daniel perhaps you could take that first
okay so um well about the new staff i
would say
from our experience that there should be
uh
one or two uh planners people who can
actually run hlds or or
do some detail design manual
modifications on the map
and there should be at least one person
who has a deeper
uh understanding of the software so
configure
the project uh i can say that we
as a as a service provider can help the
uh
the customers with the configuring the
project itself based on the
uh on the engineering roles of the
company
okay thanks mika if you've got any
thoughts on that
uh yeah uh on our side we see that uh
it would be good to have one or two
person who who has more deeper knowledge
and they are usually able to teach other
ones
if there's needn't and as i said uh
really em empower your contractor so
your
any other like what you have um on
not your company but maybe your
stakeholders
you you can definitely with it you want
to
deepen knowledge person they can teach
them and
they can do lots of things for you okay
thanks mikaev timo have you got anything
to say about that
yeah of course it's a little bit
difficult to say without knowing
exactly how the situation looks like
right now but
really we are talking about automation
so the idea is to reduce the workload
rather than rather than increase it
so typically in a system like this
so you automate a lot of the day-to-day
tasks
so you can you can reduce the workload
but of course you will need somebody
who has the capability of operating the
system
and but i would also say that i mean the
biggest
use for this kind of tool sets you will
get when
when you grow because it means that you
don't have to keep adding
new people to the organization when the
number of
customers increases
okay thanks very much um
interesting question here i think for
daniel in your opinion what are the key
success factors to adopt a design
automation
approach
well okay so i think uh um
the first one would be to to set up the
uh the
expectations properly so uh depending on
which stage of the of the design of or
the process you're in
uh you should set uh the expectations so
uh for example the input data
is a very very important uh for
uh producing the right results so
there's a different level of uh
quality of the input data for a
preliminary design than uh for
hld or detail design so these
expectations
should be set up properly beforehand
on the other side i think some
management
support is necessary especially in the
beginning as a configuration
and uh and test of automation uh
requires uh
a level of some time and resource uh
in the beginning uh and superior
performance uh
let's say uh takes a little bit of time
so
uh there's an initial investment to be
done and management vision
should uh overcome the pressure uh to
keep up the old
the old methods uh of work
okay thanks danielle uh fourth question
we have a mixed network with ftth and
vdsl can you support
both i don't know who fancy's answering
that
team maybe yeah i can start um
yemen yeah absolutely i mean our
solution can be used
for for any type of network basically
that has has
ip address but uh and
also all kind of vendors so
yeah absolutely that is possible and
actually the system is built so that
you don't have to even care if any
customer is behind the vdsl port
or or pawn port from from the
operational point of view it looks
exactly the same
okay thanks that seems to have exhausted
the questions we've got so i guess if
nobody's got any more questions we're
going to come to the end of the webinar
so thank you very much for attending
okay i hope you enjoyed it thank you
very much yeah
thank you everyone